last question today's from Jeremy Jeremy
says hey David are you worried that the
Sanders Warren candidacy are going to
candidacies I guess I'm trying to sort
of reread this in a way that makes sense
let me let me reinterpret it David are
you worried that both Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren running will split the
progressive vote if neither of them drop
out allowing the other to coalesce the
progressive vote Sanders will have an
early lead in delegates if he does well
in earlier states I think that right now
there is no reason whatsoever to believe
that both Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren running is going to hurt the
progressive movement in fact I think
right now there's a benefit to both
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren running
which is that even though they are both
considered to be sort of the leftmost
candidates that are running they
actually have different approaches and
different styles and different policy
ideas Bernie Sanders comes more from the
Democratic socialists of Enclave of the
left and he has moved to running a
campaign of social democracy Elizabeth
Warren comes more from the let's tweak
capitalism to better work for the middle
class enclave of the Democratic Party
and has moved to the left to a position
of social democracy that is also very
close to Bernie Sanders but their
approaches in terms of policy are quite
different when you look at everything
ranging from health care to education
policy to other things is one better
than the other well I think Bernie is
slightly too Elizabeth Warren's left and
I am more left so on policy I'm probably
slightly more in line with Bernie than
with Elizabeth Warren but Elizabeth
Warren is running an awesome substantive
campaign she's going to red states and
doing town halls and talking to trump
voters and other conservatives head-on
in a way that is a really great thing to
be doing and is engaging directly with
people who might never imagined that
they would vote even though I think
she's from Oklahoma for a senator from
Massachusetts in terms of the sort of
political space that Elizabeth Warren
occupies now so right now Bernie and
Warren running is a really really great
thing
eventually it's going to be sorted out
they can't both be the nominees and I
believe that they are both aware of the
impacts of each of their campaigns on
the other I believe that as the debates
get going as the polling numbers start
to firm up in terms of how they will
look as the primary start either or both
of them are going to do the right things
and in the long run I think that they
are going to grow the total base of
progressive support rather than divide
it and I think it's an absolutely great
thing
they both are people who understand
pragmatic realities they are both people
who want the movement to succeed first
and foremost and I think they're going
to do the right thing I am not worried
about that whatsoever and the way I see
it you know sometimes people say David
you know when you see other progressive
hosts growing their audience do you feel
as though they're your competition and
they're hurting you in some way the
answer is no I mean on a practical level
people only have a certain number of
hours of the day during which they
consume media so in some very strict
sense if someone starts watching a half
hour a day of something else that's a
half hour a day of me that they may not
be watching but I have a different
approach which is that progressive
independent media is such a small thing
relative to the larger universe of stuff
people can watch or listen to that I see
other progressive shows as growing the
pie rather than taking a bigger slice of
it and I think that there's a very
similar analogy to what's going on now
with the progressive movement within the
Democratic Party and even outside of it
in the United States if you disagree
with me you think Warren and Bernie
running at the same time is damaging the
progressive movement I want to hear from
you I will listen to any and all
reasonable disagreements with my
position that's it for today we've got a
great bonus show coming up the show
doesn't have to end now if you become a
member or a patron you will get instant
access to the bonus show sign up on our
website or at patreon.com slash david
pakman show